[Music]
again thank you for coming on the
program I just want to introduce you for
everyone who doesn't know this is dr.
Brian Nosek he is the director and
co-founder of the Center for open
science is that correct am I getting
that right um and he's done a lot of
work into the reproducibility crisis and
how we make science better and i think
he's a the perfect person to sort of put
it together because so far i've made a
giant mess and described the problem and
absolutely get oh yeah one of many who
described the problem you know but it's
a heart it's an easier problem to
describe than it is to put back together
so I was hoping that we could all lean
on your expertise and get a few solution
so I won't make you totally resell the
the problem because I've done a lot of
that legwork in the other videos but I'm
hoping that this interview we can really
drill in on how to make science better
yeah yeah absolutely and I think at the
core the key solution is to align
scientific values how we idealize
science to operate with what's actually
incentivized and rewarded in daily
practice and right now the core problem
is that I'm rewarded more for getting
things published rather than getting
them right and so what do I need to do
to change the behaviors in the broad
scope or the incentives so that I am
rewarded for being transparent with my
work making my work reversible and
trying to be as efficient and open as
possible so that the self-correcting
mechanisms of science can operate right
and and that's that's really the problem
we just need more self correction and
more open data more incentive because as
you said scientists that they don't feel
like they're even maybe allowed to do it
they feel like it's risking their career
to be super rigor
all these things so what what work have
you done and where are we seeing
progress in this area yeah so the
conceptual model of behavior change here
is at the base is you need technology to
be able to do the new behaviors right if
I believe in openness I believe in
reproducibility I believe
pre-registrations and then solution well
I need a place to be able to do that so
technology is one second level of the
solution is that it needs to integrate
with my research workflow I'm busy I've
got lots of things to do if you don't
make it efficient for me it's going to
be hard for me to adopt that behavior I
was to our sort of base assumptions and
then the keys on top of that are the
norms what is it that others do in my
community and just as you said well I
might believe in open data and when you
ask people researchers do you believe in
transparency almost everyone says yes
right you can't really be a scientist I
don't know you can't you just have to
trust me but people also see no one else
is doing it and so we have to address
the norms we have to show that other
people are doing it and make it so that
it's easy for me to do it on top of that
as an incentives I can't just see that
others are doing it I need to be
incentivized to be doing those behaviors
it needs to align with my interests in
order to adopt and then ultimately
policy right I need to have the policies
in place by institutions by journals and
by branding agencies to make it so that
these behaviors are in my interest and
required to be able to be a employee
great thing you can see whatever get
grants whatever okay some examples in
each level to show where progress is
being made
let's start at the top policy there is a
guidelines framework that we and many
others worked on to develop called the
top gun transparency and openness
promotion the idea of these guidelines
is to provide as a common language a
framework for what are the behaviors
that we want researchers to do collect
but it has eight different standards
open data open materials
pre-registration of studies replication
and then it has three levels of
adherence so level one is just
disclosure I don't have to share my mean
I just have to say whether it be theater
little two is required you have to
certain level three is not only do you
have to share your data before gonna
check but so the journal adopts the top
going ones then they decide what levels
of each of these different standards
they want and then those are their
policies for the researchers so and
because it's a common framework is for
any discipline to adopt and could be
adopted by funders or journals or
institutions with that particular policy
intervention we now have more than a
thousand journals that have adopted the
top guidelines and implemented these
expectations for their their authors and
all of the major publishers have at
least signed on to the guidelines even
if they haven't yet finished the
adoption process of their journals so
that's some progress right thousand
journals is not tribute that's great
progress I believe you know the leading
journals as it were at least the ones
that get a lot of attention and so
that's moving incrementally there's full
funders are starting to pay attention to
those issues and doing some have done
some leading work of adapting their
policies towards openness promotion and
the hard where its most distant right
now is with institutions haven't yet
done a whole lot of the institutional
right so that's the top policy
second-level incentives right how can we
get my interests or advancing my career
aligned with the values the best
intervention that we have so far that's
realigning incentives is register
reports right so the register reports
the idea is it's a journal based
intervention where instead of me
submitting my final work although he's
done and I need to get through a pair of
you and so I needed to have exciting
results that
reviewers will be enthusiastic about to
say this is innovative I'm going to
change everything
but this report says the primary stage
of peer review before you know what the
results are and so what changes in the
incentives is instead of me to get sexy
results I need to submit things that are
really important questions and great
methodologies to test those questions so
that the reviewers in the editor says
readability internet will do that work
that just moving peer-review two priors
knowing the results is a fundamental
change in the incentives for everybody
in the process and already we have more
than 200 journals that have adopted
register reports and the early returns
are suggesting that this is working and
how is it working well system percent of
articles published through register
reports have no results as their primary
outcome madatha it's incredible because
literature is more than 90 percent
positive results everybody always find
support for the things that they're
besties well we know that's not what's
actually Yeah right and so when you
don't know what the outcomes are the
process works as it should we're asking
important questions actually designing
tests to test them and we're finding out
what the answer is and that's getting
into the literature simultaneously those
outcomes
lots of editors say oh well that's why I
don't want to dump very short because
that's that's boring
I don't want to ever cite you know
negative results but the evidence
doesn't say yes that's true and the
results are persistently cited at least
in these are only ones as much as other
articles in the same journals so that's
an incentive based intervention and
toreador Knowles again is not trivial
what we're trying to really advance now
and register reports there's
partnerships between journals and
funders
right so now we've missed stakeholders
working together by having funder and a
journal commit to a single review
process where if you get it through a
review that the money and you get the
commitments or the grant to commitments
of the publication talk talk the people
at home back
why that's important and what is
different about the situation now yeah
so the key here is that in what I do now
in the lab is I spend all my time
writing grants and all the rest is
imposed on Celeste and all the time
writing papers and then I edit the
papers and it's two separate review
processes both of which are highly
burdensome and both critical for how it
is I can advance my career if we put
these two together into a single process
it just makes it worlds more easy for me
as an author to say here's some
interesting questions on my investigate
isn't worth me putting time into
investigating well I can submit
essentially a pre proposal to internal
and get both rewards the money and the
and the publication through a single
process Thunder is also really like this
because if so many funders fund research
that never goes anywhere right it's
conducted but it's never reported lots
of all the stuff that never gets
published got it right and so now you
get both both right the final bits of
pre-commitment
we're funding this research and Eternals
already community publishing so no one
dislikes it everybody's like yeah let's
go work and so it's still early we don't
have good with a few good pilots but not
a systemic adoption I was kind of
surprised going into this and learning
more about you know how real science
goes on not just how it is and the
movies or whatever how much time is
spent writing grants is on believable I
heard something like 20 to 30 percent of
and if you just think about that in
terms of the research missed yeah I mean
it's massive the opportunity is massive
to really change the system and get back
some of that time and just do more
research more exactly right I spend so
much time trying to get money to do the
work rather than just doing the work and
that's a real counterproductive process
in the grass
of course we need to be judicious of how
we distribute resources and things but
surely the system can be more efficient
than it is right now
so this that's a big area for innovation
exactly as you say okay so we said an
example of policy we've done an example
of incentives an example of norms right
how do we show that
well yeah everybody else has these
values but no one's doing it we have a
very simple intervention for this that's
showing some effectiveness and that is
badges so at a journal you can the
journal can say well we're going to
adopt badges for if you do some of these
behaviors like let's open data or local
materials pre-registration and if you
Republic if no paper gets accepted in
our journal and you do those behaviors
and we'll put a badge on your article
saying open beta and here's a link
that's where you can find the name or
here's a pre-registration here's linked
that's a little incentive for the
authors right oh I get some
acknowledgement for having them read but
it's a real intervention for changing
norms and that's the key right is if I
is a reader never see other people doing
these behaviors and I believe they know
it does them but no one shows that data
I don't notice it
no one pre registers I don't see it
badges are a latest signal when those
behaviors are occurring making them more
visible so that the early adopters who
are saying I just want to do this stuff
because I think it's a good thing I
don't care about the incentives I don't
care about what the culture is like I
just women do it because I believe in it
their behaviors become visible and
making their behaviors visible makes it
so that people are more inclined toward
it but I want to see that other go ahead
well when they start to do and once they
start to do it then those that are sort
of like on the fence and I'd say hello
and Susan that a lot of people maybe I
should so you can shift norms especially
if the values are present very quickly
by making them really visible the first
Journal that adopted badges was
Psychological Science and did so January
1st 2014 in the two years prior to that
in a 3% of the articles had open data in
psychological science 3% right no
alumina
after that within 18 months 40% of the
articles head open data whoa that's in
2015 right
this year 90% of the articles and psych
science have open data right the change
there is an absurd amount of change and
at worst lots of things are changing but
it has far far outpaced should the
change in other areas of psychological
science other journals and they think
the I think the role of norms is
essential here that people in the field
are here that these are important issues
they say that this journal cares about
it the journal has created this policy
framework with badges to make it visible
and someone where people do it that's
just the thing we do now that is true so
the combination of these things right
policy incentive and norms and then the
infrastructure that we and many others
also provide infrastructure ours is
called the Open Science framework just
makes it so researchers can do those
right now a place to do it is to do it
and the community norms are shaping
around so it's very early still in the
sense that all of these are promising
they're all getting adopted but we
certainly wouldn't say that these are
normative practice yet across the
research community but but it's
nonlinear growth year over year for the
last five years so that's very
encouraging for all of it and the goal
is that eventually if you can get it
normative then all of a sudden not only
does the scientists not feel like they
they can't do this they feel like
everyone's doing it and so not only can
they do it now they feel like oh man
this is how you do it science yeah right
and what's amazing about this is that
very early career researchers right grad
students who are coming into grad school
they see these behaviors they will of
course isn't that how it's always been
dominant life like the behaviors that we
are promoting our ones that everybody
assumes is how something's operates like
of course you sure you know like it's
science right so something you shared
with me that it would we
another call earlier but that I just
want it this blew my mind
so I I knew that sometimes researchers
wouldn't share their data with like the
public and I first of all I thought the
percentage of people who shared that it
was much higher than it is or at least
was but I totally assumed that every
time you submitted a paper for peer
review the peer reviewer had all your
data of course right of course of course
you would assume that of course you
would assume that and it almost never
happens the assumptions that we have
about how science operates are based on
how we buy utilized how science up and
what has happened over the years as
we've sort of implemented not even
really intentionally but what as a
culture of the process has emerged which
is very protective which is what you're
asking me for my data as you say you
don't trust me it does a hostile act in
the cultural they're really you just
should read my paper and decide whether
you like it or not from it so the even
though researchers themselves recognize
the value of transparency because it
hasn't been part of the daily practice
in any meaningful way hasn't been part
of the policy framework or the
regulatory framework of how its operates
we've gotten very used to not doing it
and so one of the biggest hurdles to get
over is just to normalize the norms
function as normal it's Odia of course
it is but once you start doing it glad
to practice like this it can shift very
quickly how could we do it any other way
does make any sense
but I mean yeah we absolutely need to
change that and you're right it's sort
of an ideology of science that we assume
we just sort of like map on to the black
box of science that a lot of us you know
the laymen do not understand we just
assume that's just how it works and so
we see the peer review like little line
and we're just like oh well this is just
100% true
to be true because it was you know peer
review that's that's just what peer
review does something else I want to
talk to you about is reproducibility and
this is another thing I mean I just like
confronting all these misconceptions in
my own head because I feel like if I
misconceived of them probably there are
a lot of people who do too so there's
again in the ideology of science which
is everything should be reproducible and
in practice that is still holds we want
them to be but there's kind of like not
much tested in that front not many
things are reproduced there's and that's
because researchers are not incentivized
nothing you don't get much career
advancement for doing reproducible
studies you did a giant reproducibility
study walk me through a little of all so
I saw that the response to that wasn't
all positive I mean first of all when
you reproduce something you're not
exactly the friends of the people who
pay for maybe you reproduced or who's
the chair of you know Harvard whatever I
forgot who got mad at you but um
everybody but how do how do we number
one incentivize reproducibility and also
their needs
I don't know that this maybe this is too
idealistic but it seems like there needs
to be a decoupling of like someone's
idea being published from holding on to
it forever as like this has to be true
like scientists get attached to it
having to be true almost as like if it's
found to be wrong I should lose my
career or something and that shouldn't
be how it is we should be open to being
wrong and opening ourselves up to okay
yeah I totally got that wrong you know
let's do better yeah yeah yeah findings
become light possessions right there my
identity I am associates like try to
defend it yeah you hit on a really
another core challenge in this whole
reform movement which is the lack of
incentives for doing replication studies
right my career advances by showing
things that are
showing something that's exciting so
it's something we haven't thought about
before but science really advances
slowly through incremental confirmation
verification qualification of the claims
that we have and so if we can't shift
the environment towards incentivizing
replication it's going to be hard to
have a efficient cumulative knowledge
base so the surprising thing in these
large replication studies that we did
and we're still where there's more and
more that are going and many more fields
are doing these sort of systematic
replication efforts great when we try to
replicate publish studies a surprising
percentage of the time we fail to
replicate the original finding now that
could be that the original result was
wrong
correctly that we screwed it up in doing
the replication or encode me that
there's some subtle difference between
reading studies that we don't recognize
without that that it's important or
relevant but in all whatever the
explanation the fact that we fail much
more frequently than we might anticipate
is suggest that we need to pay a lot
more attention to the other so that we
have our claim and so that is a
important thing to change at the same
time we don't expect in our published
literature we shouldn't expect I think
that everything is reproducible really
what science advances by pushing out the
boundaries of knowledge right isn't is
by challenging what it is then think we
understand now with what might be great
so well then have lots of false starts
lots of false leads lots of areas where
we thought something exciting was
happening and then once we follow up it
turns out not to be true that's totally
ok and in fact that's a signal of a
healthy science but to your point just
when you're just saying that people are
holding on to these as possessions right
now once something gets into the
literature it's hard to get it out in
the sense that science isn't very
efficiently so
correct yeah we're not challenging our
findings effectively and that's partly
because we're not doing the replication
studies but that also is starting to
change there are many more replication
replication is involved in some way the
notion that replication is boring has
been the monster is demonstrably false
people get very very very riled up with
replication now and it's very exciting
and lots of debate and some people want
many people energized and so that is
have been a very positive reorganization
of how people think about replication is
it's a way to confront our existing
understanding and see where it needs to
be improved yeah no I think that's
exactly right I mean to your point I saw
something where they go you know how
much of the literature would you expect
in a really healthy scientific community
to be replicable and nobody was thinking
a hundred percent nobody thinks all
studies should be true the important
thing though as you said is that when
they are wrong we should be reasonably
we should reasonably expect that we do
catch these things and hopefully as soon
as possible to realize that oh this path
is completely useless we should you know
pivot off to a new direction and that's
where sort of the problem is is if you
don't have incentives you know
scientists are not martyrs they're not
we should not expect them to like
stake their career and like throw away a
good career in order to be heroes in the
scientific you know like don't get paid
much to replication we should
incentivize these things and incentivize
the people basically going back with a
fine-tooth comb and be like wait is this
this should be a regular part of science
and I want to get your your point on
this first first how can we you know you
said we're more and more normalizing
that is there any kind of injunction
we're making on the journal level or
anything like that and then - do you
think that I've seen all the claims of a
replication crisis around psychology
mostly and biomedicine and there's sort
of an epistemic superiority around
you know you know the physics chemistry
I want to get your take on that
maybe yeah so I guess I guys do two
questions I will answer the second one
first and it is very much there is
mostly attention has been on psychology
and biomedicine but by and large because
those are the communities that are
actually looking so yes it may be that
there are bigger challenges in some
fields and others I don't actually have
a good evidence base to assess that yet
because every community that has started
to examine the reproducibility of its
findings has found it to be below what
they might expect I have found areas
where replication has not been easy and
it's hardly characterized at a
discipline level what the replica of
replicability rate actually is right
there's all kinds of places of variation
like in my field psychology there are
some areas where replicability is very
very high others where it's low and so
we're still trying to unpack where is it
that this is a challenge why is it a
challenge in some place so that the I
think as the broader research community
it looks at this more closely they will
we you collectively will find that it is
a challenge for everyone and there are
some ways to make it more efficient and
better operating than others in some
fields will be even the others will be
followed that's so then you have a
incentivizing but yeah yeah yeah so yeah
this is an interesting challenge because
new and exciting findings are drivers of
new directions right just because what
it is is more exciting than the
verification efforts that happens with
replication it's possible to have new
innovative ideas come out of replication
efforts and maybe your frequent well we
sort of have to acknowledge that there's
likely to be an outstanding difference
there so there are a number of different
things that research communities are
doing the basic fact of replication is
now understood in some areas to be
publishable is a big step because a lot
of this replications have been getting
done they're just getting filed people
do them to try to get mastery in a new
area to see or fail to replicate it and
then put that data aside and go and do
innovative novel research where so that
is helping but enough that this is an
area where funders can play a
particularly good role which is to
actually make calls for replication
studies four areas of research that are
important right researchers need with
money funders sending a signal that the
replication is valued can be really
useful and there are some really
innovative ways that that could be
conducted as well so funders can do
things like say here are the top ten
studies that were published by a
research that we funded in the past past
five years we've identified these as the
most amazing findings readable fund
replications of those ten studies just
proposed specifically how you can
conduct those all kinds of things where
we could use resources in a very
efficient way to target those things
that are the most important findings the
things that are changing the direction
of a discipline to work on verification
so that instead of spending a hundred
million dollars on the preclinical
clinical pipeline and then discover that
it wasn't actually reproducible finding
you spend a lot less money upfront seen
okay yeah this part we understand this
part we don't understand here or having
some chance or whatever but get that
verification initially to then justify
the bigger investments and this seems
like four yeah like particularly
interesting I think you've hinted at it
in like medicine and things like that
where the application really matters and
you end up actually just pouring a ton
of money into it anyways yes and so as
you say like an injunction early on
could be possibly more so efficient
right to be able to have that
intervention yeah yeah okay so give me
like I I know
time's wrapping up here give me like a
horizon of the open science movement the
good thing is that we're seeing progress
yeah of course the bad thing is is that
we've only we've just seen how big the
problem is right and so it's easy to get
a little bit like I'm like making two
videos and I have a whole interview
about how bad the problem is one of
which is your story of you know your
story of feeling like okay I'm I shot
myself in the foot by doing a
replication you know so so so talk us
through whether you're optimistic what
what you see the landscape in yeah well
I am congenitally optimistic so that
will always be the case but I think
there's good reason to be optimistic
here the challenges are big but the huge
lever that we have is that the research
community already recognizes almost
universally that the culture of
incentives is not ideal that that
changing it would be great and that's
been a dustman understood for a long
time but what's different this time
what's different now is that the
stakeholders in science are getting
together to actually make change and
there is a substantial grassroots
movement across different disciplines of
people saying what we can change this
right there's an activism component of
recognizing that the culture exists
because the members of the culture
already exist and that we can change
that culture of incentives and norms and
policies and practices so the the
mindset I think is in the right place
for change we also are seeing adoption
of some of these solutions right we know
what the behaviors are that need to be
done pre-registration should share in
your data your materials here research
process there are there are physical
infrastructure solutions to help make
that happen
and these norms and incentives and
policies are gaining adoption and so
that nonlinear growth as long as we can
continue advancing that as a collective
we will see
and the next component I think beyond
that if you're talking to sort of
horizon is yeah okay we're now seeing
what people are doing but how can we
make it more credible how can we up
their game of the quality of the
research and one of the projects that
I'm most excited about for this patek
mists or horizon time is called scholar
and the goal of score is to create
automatic measurement indicators of
research credibility so as everything
else
let's let the machines figure it out for
us machines read the papers that are
coming out of in science and gives the
findings scores this one's a 97 we can
really trust it this one's a 32 I don't
know about that one right if we can
validate machine learning methods for
assessing initial credibility of claims
and it could dramatically improve our
efficiency of identifying areas of
uncertainty in the ecosystem of
scientific evidence so that we can much
more efficiently direct our resources to
seyn that's really important but it's
got a little school around so sure about
it let's follow up on that and this
right refers there are credible and we
can trust well yeah translate that to
policy
that I think is really going to be
transformative if if it will work and so
there's a massive project that we're a
part of and many other groups are
involved in and it's a huge
collaboration where they have their
people of all it's here to contribute to
assess the credibility of research
claims with experts and then have
machines try to assess the credibility
of those claims and then we're running
replications of a subset of them to
validate whether the experts always like
this huge training set to get machines
kind of spun up on how to read
scientific findings the importance of
like sample sizes versus like power
versus you know all these different
metrics that's really interesting that's
really cool yeah my only one my only
concern and this is more just like
cynicism
well I and actually so you know good
hearts law yes sir so I'd be a little
bit worried that like everyone would
then start figuring out how do I get the
perfect shoe what do I of course
what do i optimize you know what is what
a machine you're hearing about now what
people absolutely so luckily as we know
from the Terminator service the machines
will wholly stay a step ahead and so
they'll just keep innovating against us
and the fight will be glorious but we'll
see movie did something that never quite
ends yeah well you're right that's a big
challenge awesome awesome
well I think that's a good way to end it
and optimistic cool ideas on terminator
that's with also some challenges in the
terminator that's really awesome what
once again I just want to thank you I
like I I don't think even my viewers
know what a treat it is to have you on I
mean you're like I was actually shocked
when I got to on the show and I'm really
appreciative of your time I know you're
like a huge voice in this whole movement
oh thanks there's a lot of fun to chat
and I'm glad that you're trying to
translate a lot of these issues for the
more general public to understand what
we're wrestling with because it's a very
exciting time in science
[Music]